yeah welcome to this video against
Yardbird let's see Erik LeBron GM he's
basically retired from from tournament
chess I'm not quite sure why I haven't
seen him play in a long time but he's
very active here on the internet playing
on the ICC I don't know maybe on other
platforms but he's a very frequent
player on the ICC so on we have a pretty
ancient version of the new zones image
and it's usually considered to be quite
quite good for white this disposition
but okay let's see Knight to g3 to play
you fall on should I take yeah let's
let's take him play between him this is
a simple way to play this is a very
similar to the absolutely classic game
but vinik against kappa blanka from his
1938 I'm not sure about the year and all
I know this games but I'm as sometimes I
get confused with with the years um okay
um this this was the classic game right
at the end put Vinick played with Bishop
e3 this very well known long sacrificial
line okay here my ideas to play a form
I'm trying to to get this this perfect
pawn Center but I need to support my
center here so that I can play for and I
hope that next move
I can finally play it
efore and then he 5 then 94 this is the
the thing that widest is planning I
played rugby 1 because after a vortex
takes 95 or the technical idea that you
need to be aware of this is why play
droop do you want to cover the Queen so
I'm not sure what he's supposed to do
now
maybe Queen c7 something like that
intending I would have rook c1 yeah I
thought Queen c7 intending Queen c2 or
Quincy for hmm no I know any form I
always like this kind of position for
white I must admit with the default
always seems to me to be Dane dangerous
for black ok let's see what he is coming
up with those Knights can can be really
clumsy if white yeah this is a rather
typical IDM attacking the noise
yeah I still think I should do that
so if I don't play you for this whole
thing doesn't make much sense maybe
there's some technical idea now puzzle
like g6 yeah or this kind of stuff
muddying muddying the waters but okay
yeah well okay if I he wants to take
here I came probably prone yeah let's
let's do that
this of course help like to some extent
a play if ever played if I would have
taken on g2 and I cannot recapture
because of 9f form so hmm but now he
always has this this very annoying pawn
him like who in g2 mate it's it's far
away from that I know but still and five
yes
d5 that is squeegee to mate okay I've
got yeah I have 93 but guy is such a
tricky player
I've played him a very often and he sees
his getting outplayed also really often
but he's very tricky okay what to do now
night
III
and I've got this bloody Czechia young
king of two
I don't know going it 22 yeah 22 looks
looks bad somehow
what is this next move if I play like
this come on let's do that yeah I didn't
Queen d5
night FB for something this bloody pong
on age three yeah I knew it I knew that
this could could be could be the big
issue
okay now and now if I move the rookies
getting only five great great so I need
to go to see - um maybe night night III
I could have considered
yeah this is the same uniform is this
possibility no 97 somehow 97 I'm just
destined to tricking
yeah I'm gonna have it kappa to deform
that's absolutely no way to get get rid
of this to get rid of this pawn or blame
go here is taking on deform
yeah I don't see a move you have a good
one cannot move this this is her nose
don't see move
what deck
time warning
check no I didn't see the check
there are many ways to window
you know I don't know check white for
its own time yeah no let's have a look
how hard to avoid that because I'm
pretty sure that this cannot be too
great for black but so mm-hmm so d5 is
the move okay what is an index in in
shape but okay but have it sits and
simply 25 d5 is the right booth why this
almost winning here but the thing is you
you you you feel that this is bad for
black him and he's giving me a perfect
center this Knight is excellent this
Bishop is excellent and there should be
something but I just played if I've to
quickly embed on the clock here and I
completely overlooked Queen d5 if he
doesn't have Queen d5 black is busted
for nothing but this is completely turns
the table okay this is even but it's
still better for what according to the
comp but okay this is very tricky now
and but this is this is very strong the
ideas after takes less d6 yeah this is
this is strong of course everything is
perfect now so this kind of idea
yeah but this is this is difficult for a
blitz game in the tournament game this
is pretty clear when if you have some
minutes to figure out what's going on
here but okay I completely overlooked
Queen d5 so this this really let into
into trouble immediately so now yeah 93
now I'm 93 is winning again but I found
what what's the problem I've got 21 I've
got simply going to d1 here
I only thought 94 I thought okay this is
not on yeah but I can't go to d1 of
course so then then it's pretty clear
that this is also good for white where
is it going something like this is just
I've got a center it's worth something
yeah this this kind of stuff is is
excellent for what the Knights don't
have any support okay so I only spotted
later even this was right
yeah but this is very very tough to play
now why didn't I take this yeah because
I had 15 seconds probably I should
simply take this I mean just just for
getting rid of one of those terrible
nights and now here this is in fact
still quite quite nice for white with
the center so yeah it's uh still
playable
okay but I was so down on time it of
course this Queen d5 is a very important
resource this intermediate move okay
yeah one an interesting game is always
interesting to playing and she was a
very inventive player thanks for
watching